i'm on the show
absolute normie
how's it going bro oh my gosh
how's everybody
how are you how wonderful
you are reading uh dude you know what's
funny though
i've been uh i have only read like half
a book since
the big bang because i just can't read
it anymore
i will try to read once in a while
because because before i had this
condition of i
wanted to be really smart and really
intelligent and really creative that was
one of the
the conditioning i totally let go of if
i wake up tomorrow morning in iq of 75
i would not give a [ __ ] at all i'll be
like okay okay i cute what is that
okay sorry but before i was really
obsessed with like gaining knowledge
and trying to be have a big brain and
stuff i'll read three hours a day i'll
go to the clubs
and even when i go to the clubs i'll
wait in line i'll have like a book of
philosophy
we didn't like wittenstein and while i
was waiting to go to the club and [ __ ]
girls
to satisfy both like my intellectual
desire
and my sexual desire but from the
perspective of the natural state which
is what we're going to talk about
they're actually all the same thing
but i just randomly went and picked up
this book from my
closet yesterday philip k day baby baby
and the dude so weird after realization
everything that you pick up
has something that's that has the the
fruit of the
um the state in it it has
i mean why not right because everything
is made up of it right but some books
are more direct than others so
let me just read you one quote that
pretty much is gonna
sum up a lot of what we're gonna talk
about there's so many good quotes in
here
um in movies too i don't know man
netflix i've been watching out
loud on netflix almost every show on
netflix
you can extrapolate and be like this is
non-duality
this is spirituality this is about um
emptiness god realization whatever you
want to call it but anyway listen to
this
eternity is a kind of measure but to be
measured belongs not to god
therefore it does not belong to him to
be eternal that's [ __ ] deep bro
one just think
thousands of people unif
no one possessing
right i read like 10 pages and there's
only like three quotes in there that
pretty much sums up everything we're
going to talk about so anyway so sorry
for that rambling
during the second quote on my end at
least you cut out can you just repeat
the second quote
just in case
wait are you frozen or what
can you hear me
on my end you cut out wow second quote
we will be right back after a short
break
[Laughter]
what happened you're just frozen you're
smiling and i thought you were just
smiling
okay you froze during the reading of the
second quote so
reread the second quote for us okay so
okay fine okay so everything else before
that was okay get edited right
yeah except we're not going to edit it
but yeah but but
that's fine but but it's not gonna
people are not gonna wait for five
minutes right
okay so we had a little technical
difficulty we had a little suggestion in
here
okay small here here's a quote want to
come
you'll be exciting just think thousands
of people unified into one entity
the ut he calls it which is everyone and
no one
possessing absolute knowledge because he
has no
single limiting viewpoint
anyway i just read two quotes from this
book that i've been reading that
pretty much summarizes everything we're
going to talk about so it's very
interesting
when you disappeared during that
cessation i mentioned to the audience
that we were having a
minor break until you
pop back in so it works out great start
with those coats
a little follow-up to that would be as
you all know
frank has been quite adamant
about people reading let's see if i can
get this to
show up there we go adiashanti's the end
of your world
and
as frank mentioned a moment ago at times
it can feel like the
attention is not focused
and that you can't get through reading
and i would question that
and ask yourself are you propagating a
victim script
oh i can't read
a book anymore that's a good point
it's a really good point there's a lot
of people promulgating this
victim script of i'm i live in the
information
age now i can't read a book bruh
you recommended this and i read it in
two days
because i [ __ ] cared to read it
that's all you have to do
if you put a little fire under your ass
you can finish reading
you know 100 pages in a day without a
problem
but you have to have a little fire under
your ass and you actually have to read
for like 10 hours of the day
and take good notes highlight good
things while you read
but the point is is that nisargata and
so many
other of the greatest spiritual teachers
and mystic traditions have said desire
earnestness is number one how [ __ ]
bad do you want to know your true nature
that's it true very true so just the
only thing
curiosity because dude man how hard is
it
to go back to your true nature it's not
that it's right here it's right in front
of you it's
just it doesn't take 40 years bro that's
nothing we're going to talk about
how i think i think one of the reasons
why it takes some people 40 years to get
to their natural state
is because they're stuck in the
spirituality paradigm
they identified themselves as a seeker
yes
and if spirituality is all about
dissolving
conditionings of the separate self
spirituality is a great program for that
right
spirituality is what i call the meta
program is the mother of all programs
that's used to dissolve
all the previous programs we can list
them all people will be
they identify with a lot of them the ceo
program the nofap program
the post-modernism program you know
science program atheism program the
pickup program
the philosophy program the science
program the bodybuilding program you
went to the mall in life you're like
holy [ __ ]
that doesn't satisfy me and finally you
hop on this whole spirituality
program and now you see things now
and use spirituality as a program to
dissolve the other programs but
spirituality itself
after you sort of accumulated all the
fruits and all the
levels something in this game you
acquire all the wisdom all the genres
whatever all the insights spirituality
as a whole program must also
self-destruct
for you to return to the natural state
[Music]
that's right it's a good segue into
jumping into the stages
that is as frank just described to you
in these short stages that is this
fifth stage transcending the entire
paradigm of spirituality itself that
very
natty state the natural state
so we'll go ahead and pull up towards
this
long definition of the stages
first and a brief entry
into that we're just going to mention
that each stage has three levels
there's the more intellectual
there's the experiential and the
realized and it's important to be
sincere and honest with which
level you are at with each stage
so let's go ahead and have frank kick us
off with
the stages defined long
okay let's do it so um
before i go into the stages i just want
to remind people that all those stages
are just references uh just like the
quote that i read
nothing can no labels can't touch
this um but during the path it's very
valuable to have stages
i mean it helped myself and a lot of
other people and if you look at a lot of
different research
about the different stages of wicking
that actually people go through like
worship jeffrey martin
or even the theravada four path model
whether
the models that are you know uh
advocated by people like daniel ingram
or whatever tradition that you're in
there's always gonna be some kind of
stages in there
except for the really radical non-dual
teachers but usually people
do go through different stages among
goldman
and uh the stage we're going to talk
about if you really want to match it
you can match it to any school any
tradition
and it would make sense uh
stage number one is ego state stage of
separation
basically you're identifying yourself
with this character inside the mitsu
your sense of identity your sense of
self is
behind the eyes inside the head or
somewhere in the midsum
you're contracted
you're separated from the rest of the
environment there's a huge
gap between the subject and the object
okay second stage you have the awareness
and consciousness phase
this is where i would say 95 of
mainstream spiritual teachers talk about
they tend to abide in
awareness they tell you that your true
self is awareness
or abide in consciousness or witness
observer whatever
the reason for that is because after you
see through that the ego
is an illusion that is just a
fabrication
you have to move your sense of identity
to a larger ground after you have more
spiritual openings and glimpses
and then you sort of disidentify from
the ego and now your identification is
with this new ground of awareness and
consciousness
now this is a very vast infinite
spacious field
almost but there's still an observer
here
there's still someone that's observing
the ego
and the next step is to unplug even that
to dissolve
even the observer to be aware of
awareness
to witness the witness observe the
observer
and if you can't witness anything or
observe anything you can still
just identify from it you can still
objectify it
and you realize that the observer is
just actually more solidified sensations
in the field of experience that's taking
credit for
nature or the universe at first it was
the ego taking credit for it you have
this huge
block of solidity like a marble taking
credit trying to take credit
or you didn't and then
awareness trying to take credit for
infinity
so now your new identification is
awareness and the reason
people ask you to abide awareness is not
this is a very important point it's not
to create a new identity
out of awareness and be like i am
awareness i mean that is that better
more spacious identity than the ego but
feel an identity
after you unplug given awareness you
dissolve even the observer
you move into the third stage which is
what i call the god stage
uh this is the infinity stage you know
the creator
being christ consciousness ottoman
big self true self love existence
the universal mind and this third stage
is what i call the pinnacle of
spirituality
the pinnacle of spiritual experiences
anyway maybe not the thing of
spirituality but the pinnacle of human
especially experiences
and a lot of people think this is it
which it could be i mean every stage is
completing it of itself
don't get me wrong every single stage
every aspect
of the jewel the multiplicity of jewel
of enlightenment is complete
so we're not really making a hierarchy
it's more like
horizontal
anyway at the start at the third stage
we identify with the godhead
with the universal mind but there is
still a very subtle
very subtle identification because even
at this point at this stage
the separation hasn't been completely
dissolved so you feel like you're
merging with the divine
as long as there's merging there's still
very subtle sense of duality
so that's why i want to make a very
clear distinction between you as a
separate
person experiencing the divine versus
just a divine
recognizing itself universe [ __ ]
itself
versus you trying to [ __ ] the universe
there is a big distinction there anyway
so after the third stage we move on to
nuttiness after expansion what do we get
we did contraction
this whole process is about expansion
and contraction after you expand to
infinity
you shrink down from the big bang to the
big crunch down to the singularity of
nothingness emptiness nirvana numbing
or brahman death non-existence
so basically three and four are two
sides of the same coin
so at this phase um you have this very
nebulous sense of self total loss of
identity
where the third stage you go around
saying hey i am god
and the second say yo hey bro i'm
consciousness don't you get it i want to
spirituality i
am consciousness and thursday you i su
consciousness no i'm god
and the fourth stage dude it's not like
he said he said hey i know
i don't even know what i know anymore
total loss of identity you have this
really vague anabolic sense of self that
you can't define at all
and this is kind of like the stuff that
buddha talks about
the emptiness the originations
where you disidentify
from even god consciousness because if
you can be aware of
god consciousness if you can experience
god consciousness
is still an object within your field of
experience that you can
still disidentify and objectify and make
it not self
and not this not that so we're doing
something korean
along the way right um and after this
phase
you slip into the natural state now this
is very very tricky
because stage three and four a lot of
people would
get stuck on a stage thinking this is it
which again i completely understand
because i've been there
and again each stage is complete but
there's more to the picture there's more
to the fast different
jewels of the enlightenment the
nothingness face
um if you can still experience
this very subtle sense of lost sense of
self
so to speak there's still an experience
there if there is an experience
you can still witness it objective from
it and after you disidentify
and disembed all the previous stages
spontaneously you move to this
fifth stage what i call true no self or
the natural state the towel
so this stage not only transcend all the
other stages
it includes them as well because the
only way to truly embody something
is to disidentify from it if you let go
of it it becomes yours even more fully
and all the previous stages all the
experiences all the mind-blowing
exceptions you had
that can be experienced even more fully
paradoxically without the experiencer in
the middle
and this is the whole process is to
dissolve the center point
if you want to boil this down to the i
guess the microscopic level
it's all about dissolving sensations and
the last piece of sensation to get
dissolved from solidity to emptiness is
usually somewhere in the center in the
head
before it was in the body but then you
keep shredding [ __ ] and shedding and it
was in the head
and even if this last little bit of
speck of sensation is as tiny as an atom
it's still going to project itself onto
a new ground and the smaller this atom
is
the bigger this ground is and to get to
a natural state you have to dissolve not
just the ego
but the background as well the
background that gets created from the
separated state
and say oh even though my identity is
this tiny little thing here that i can't
even find
in the middle of my experience that's
still gonna kind of
hang on to some sort of a ground some
sort of source like brahman or like
godhead
and very subtly you're still gonna think
hey i am from i am god
this is just a godhead this is my idea
shantae
um said that um not alicia we'll get you
out of the channel later but
this is what i said if realizing true
self
of no self is like perceiving the world
without the eyeball
because the eyeball can't see itself but
you can see everything else
so if you really truly recognize no self
you're not going to be able to
experience or even sleep in those talk
if you still have the sense of oh i'm
looking for the self but i can't find it
oh it's infinite that's still not true
no self there's true no self
there's nothing you can say about it but
the eyeball that
nothing could be said about can see
things
and the manifestation of this what it
sees
you can describe and there's infinite uh
levels to the manifestation
um if that's
finding out your true self uh an eyeball
that can't see itself another analogy
that's similar is
a mirror versus no mirror
first you have a source you perceive the
world as
phenomenon rising and passing out of a
mirror the mirror could be any ground
that you encounter in the past
with the consciousness or awareness or
the god mind
but after you truly dissolve separation
if the ego is gone so is the so is the
mirror so is the sword so is the ground
so you have to deconstruct even the
background
you have to do self-increase with the
self the small cell the ego
and then you have to do self include the
big self you have to be selfish
with the god mind but to do that you
first have to access the god mind
you have to access and identify with
something before you could decide
benefit from it
so all that's why all these different
paths have to be sort of
go through you go through each one of
them and then you just identify for them
but by this satisfying problem you
actually disappear into them
and if you disappear into them you
actually manifest them even more forward
so they're only reflections but no
mirror at the end
there's only a manifestation there's no
unmanifested
there's no source no background the
unmanifested is just something that you
imagine
because how can there be something
that's not manifested if it's
non-duality
if this is one thing right there's only
the manifesto
there's no mirror that's the answer to
the
zen colon what is the sound of one hand
clapping
that's that that's the answer to that
quran
they actually called there's actually
this damn master or maybe
i think he was reading some uh some poem
or something that he student wrote
and first his student was writing about
oh man the mind is like a mirror i have
to shine in the mirror
and everything's just coming in and out
this buddha my this natural mind
but then after that he realizes wait a
second this mirror this buddha
is also just a construction and then he
said there's no mirror
that [ __ ] up
okay that was a little thank you
there we go thank you a little
presentation
it could be helpful for potentially
me to do the
short version and also unpack the
stages with the levels
because that's a big way of how i've
been
experiencing realizing yeah
so to play on what frank just unpacked
for us
all right before before we go i just
want to say one more thing if you find
the stage
the stage is very complicated just
remember one thing this whole spiritual
path is about one thing
this solution of the conditions that
makes up the separate self
the more you dissolve the more glimpses
of reality which is formless it's opened
up
and all those mystical experiences that
you experience are just a byproduct of
this realization itself is not an
experience
bigger this my bowling field is gonna
and the separate self both disappear
without the subject
there won't be an object even the object
that is god consciousness eventually
dissolves and there's just this
the absolute normie
now you're free to put on different
lenses of perception
as you see fit
did we freeze again you did for a moment
but now you're back
can you hear me
we had another cessation experience
thank you everyone for tuning in
thanks for all your love in the comments
oh man where did i get caught off again
there's another succession that happened
sorry
that's exactly what i was just saying
sweating okay you
you covered
you're finishing covering dissolving the
conditions of the separate self being
what everything is pointing at
yeah so basically the entire picture
path if you find this whole map too
complex
just remember that the whole process is
the solution of the separate self in
this condition that's it
the more you dissolve the bigger opening
you're gonna get
that's why the stages of awareness and
god and nothingness whatever right
um so if the separation is completely
dissolved when the subject
in the center is completely bandaged so
is the background the background is also
going to vanish
so it's not like there's really
ultimately no difference between ego
awareness infinity and it's all the same
they're just different reconfiguration
and solidity of sensations which we're
going to talk about in a bit what
sensations are
but perfect
yes because looking
back let's say
10 years or so for most of us
all of this was present
all five of these were present yes yes
and that's always what's so funny that's
why it's the cosmic
and we just didn't know
that what we were we didn't know our
true nature
and so we thought because we had fallen
into the illusion of the contracted
separate self-conditioning and identity
which
very much so is promulgated by
the civilization
by the mainstream by
our family friends and even spirituality
it's not really acatoli and we've had to
identify with presence and
and
there are specific traditions around
the planet especially indigenous
lineages where
the child is birthed
into recognition of the natural state
off the bat which is really interesting
so the contraction doesn't form which is
really interesting
so when we talk about spirituality and
we talk about
pedagogies for an awakened civilization
one of the core components of that as
we bring these educational platforms
into virtual reality and whatnot for
kids to experience is in essence it's
the
prevention of the egoic separate
conditioned self from forming
correct and seeing that natural state
right off the bat
so now that we've sort of been looking
back like what we were like about
10 years ago or so it gives us a better
understanding
of what this staged system has been
over the past 10 years let's say
and really it starts off
with the question the bigger
your question and the stronger your
desire and earnestness to have it
answered the faster you will know your
true nature
so the sufi metaphysic goes
only the ignorant seek what's already
there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
so it's already there but yet it remains
for you to recognize it
and so your quality of your life in many
ways is the quality of your questions
and so if you start off with the big
questions
what is consciousness what is the nature
of reality
who am i and why am i here
if you just start off with these big
picture metaphysical questions
what you will do is you will immediately
you know ramana papaji have talked about
this you're basically
fanning the fire that's burning
of this big question of this big
metaphysical question
and so that's what gets you to go okay
what is god what is the absolute
what is mysticism which means union with
that
what is that process why do i not
already feel
like i am fat that's a core question
why do i feel like i am not already
that why do i feel like i am not already
perfect
freedom itself
why has my identity
fallen into a separate conditioned self
rather than the entirety of
life
and so that's a really powerful starting
point and then that's what leads you to
as you go and find all of these
different information sources across
the mystic traditions and across
retreats
and across entheogens and across
aphorisms and books
and all of these profound things what
you're doing is you're slowly like frank
said
you are deconditioning
what you've been conditioned with as
this egoic separate self
contracted identity and so slowly
in that process of deconditioning
you can go from this first
to this second stage and it's i
typically
reference it as a pop
because in very many ways it's
it feels like you've never actually
been aware of your awareness or you've
never been conscious of consciousness
you were never you were eckhart tolle
talks about it like habitually
overlooking
or perpetually overlooking the fact that
you can see
like awareness is not profound at all so
i'm just gonna focus on objects
and perceptions and sensations and
desire
and dopamine here in a relationship or a
that type of mentality we never were
so in
awe about the fact that we were
conscious ever
we never noticed that we truly wow we
have the power to know
the power to know itself so it's a big
pop in a sense into this like oh my gosh
consciousness awareness the power to
know
holy [ __ ] like we call stream entry
stream entry yes like
like it's so on that in itself is so
ineffable because you're like reality is
dependent
on this power to know it's so
unbelievably beautiful
we are the designers of the power to
know
what the and so you know this
stream entry where basically it means
that
upon this you're pretty much guaranteed
to continue your way down to the ocean
you're pretty much guaranteed and
the more earnestness the more desire the
more fanning of the flame that you
have the more you'll actually pop into
these
next stages but like frank indicated
earlier
it is also a likelihood that
you will get be awareness just chill
you're good bruh your awareness bruh
that's good
before the the condition of the separate
self is completely
uh dissolved
you're always gonna find a new identity
and the point of that
is to dissolve even more your body
awareness so you can continue to
dissolution
of the separate self not to reattach
your identity to that awareness
i mean of course in emptiness and just
you know even in natural state of course
there's awareness duh right but there's
a very
subtle difference between the
self-identifying awareness
versus just awareness being itself and
at the natural state you're not going to
even
label your experiences awareness it
doesn't occur to you with the natural
state
this is awareness that's why i say you
dissolve your awareness not like i'm not
aware
would you ask a dog or a cat
what is awareness you know about
consciousness and awareness
it's something you read from
spirituality books or in various
st paris uh meditation app they're like
hey the nature of reality is
consciousness
that in the top is just an idea that
itself is just an idea
it's not i'm not saying we're not
conscious i'm just saying consciousness
it actually just know the projection
an experience here sure in reality
reality is the universe is neither
consciousness nor not consciousness it
cannot be defined
not even by consciousness and if you
stand on the ground of consciousness
automatically you're going to pull all
those different theories and ideas and
experiences about consciousness
from stuff that you read and that
process
is already better out more conditions
and you get mad at people for not
understanding consciousness
you're like hey man everything's
conscious don't you get it
you're not a person you're consciousness
and you get mad and you're not just
saying you don't get mad like that
because you do that it's all you just
don't get mad at stuff like that anymore
because you're not attached to the
identity of even consciousness
you man i gotta i need to plug this
[ __ ]
yeah yeah go ahead and i'll i'll explain
yeah and i'll explain where what you
just said is super important and
resonant with
this short definition the is defined
short
is it's really important to not
fall into the crevices along the way
which ad yashanti talks about like
superiority man
especially ego spiritual ego is another
one yeah enlightened ego
yeah and
for example what happened to me in
december
when i went from this december 2020
this pop from ego
separation although there was so much of
this
understanding of oneness so much of it
but not and this is a great way to talk
about how each
stage has these levels
where you could say that in a sense my
understanding of oneness was very
intellectual
and so in december
what happened in this shift this
pop was my first you could say
experiential true experiential taste
of awareness of consciousness
and so what happened also at the
same time as
this experiential
level to the second stage so you see how
we're talking about this now so it's a
level two experiential about
stage two awareness the
moment that i popped into that of course
there was the whole
rewiring of the energy of the entity
itself
crying just i can't believe it was here
the whole time
type thing but also
the ego it comes back and it makes
an identity out of
the awareness it makes an identity
and so if you can be vigilant if you can
be
aware of when your ego tries to grasp
onto the stages and make a new spiritual
identity out of it
and it's a very natural part of the
process as adi shanti and so many others
of the mystic traditions have talked
about
it's just very natural for as you sort
of go through these stages
to have the ego come back and grasp
on to the new achievement and then
create a new identity for people to see
the entity algorithm
oh because then you're getting your your
child all those childhood conditionings
of separation
are now being validated by other people
because you have some sort of
metaphysical credits now
and so i fell into this trap that's why
i'm speaking about it from experience
and by the way the same thing happened
to me
with this so
um again you can say that
this transition from awareness to
infinity
is very fascinating as well because
the intellectual understanding of
infinity
is when you do things like you look at
the
benoit mandelbrot infinite fractal zoom
and so you're watching this math
be infinitely
zoomed and showing this beautiful
fractal-like complexity
that just never ends and then you're
like oh that's infinity you know that's
probably what we are and it's very
intellectual
and it's so beautiful um in it because
these are easy sort of ways or if you
look at m.c escher's work
which we've talked about quite a bit on
the show as well and douglas hofstetter
featured him in gerda escherbach
and you know his work also barry
intellectually tries to pop you into an
experiential knowledge
of infinity and so i remember in
february or so of 2021
frank yang posted his
infinity visualization
and right when that was sort of the
moment when i
again sort of popped i was like oh [ __ ]
this is infinity [ __ ] itself oh my
gosh and so that was sort of my like
okay
now it's a little bit more experiential
and so
now there's this okay well what is true
infinity
in pure potential infinite possibility
that's what we are
that and and so then there's this
process of
again the ego comes in and it's like oh
it's infinity now you should make your
identity about infinity
make your identity about that um
as frank likes to say um be a spiritual
[ __ ]
have everybody see you as a spiritual
[ __ ] you know
you know uh you have the truth and so
that kicked in and then
this most recent sort of
another you could say going from i am
everything pure potential endless you'll
never come to the end of that pure
potential
which actually we talked about on that
first episode together where i was going
through that explanation to you which
was
how many different ways can you color a
blank canvas how many ways can you
arrange musical notes into a song how
many ways can you modulate a screen
etc this is another way to perceive this
thing where we also showed that the
visualizations was the loop
is the infinite loop the figure where
after you
dissolve most of your centers uh after
you dissolve
the center point of the ego infinity
just loops back on itself
like this cosmic snake biting some tail
kind of picture
right
this one is really cheeky though
because as frank was indicating there's
much of spirituality is taught around
getting you from ego to
consciousness or awareness and then
let alone are the two sides of the coin
of
of infinity and emptiness really played
around with
that much and
so again this was like last year i was
looking at no
self and anata and studying and it was
kind of
it was kind of setting in intellectually
maybe a little bit
but there was no experience around
emptiness or
nirvana being blown away you could say i
had a little glimpse
of what this was at my first theravada
buddhism 10 day
meditation retreat my first sit
vipassana
and so you can get these little glimpses
but that's not ex
it's a taste of the experiential but
it's definitely not it's sitting in
experientially and so what
for me was a big pivotal moment
going from this i am everything i am
infinity
to i am nothing to i am emptiness
is
in a sense cessation is probably the
best way to put it
it's like
that's that's it there's just there's
nothing to be able to say
about what it feels like when there is
nothing there is no atlas there is no
creation there is this dream is
popped
the mind is not in a state of
it's just there's nothing
go ahead um yeah the see everything
before
the natural state could be said to be an
experience
um there are realizations within this
all the stages but the last stage
the natural state is purely in
realization
because that's when the experiencer gets
dissolved
before the experiencer gets dissolved
you go through those stages they're
still going to be experiences and all
spiritual and mystical experiences
are mostly just a by-product the
response
to the realizations that you have so you
can go through the different levels of
realization from ego to awareness or
infinity to emptiness
and before because the experiencer
hasn't been completely dissolved
it's always going to respond to separate
entity that's still there it's always
going to
respond to reality in different ways and
if you get like a bliss or ecstasy or
you know a joy you get a spiritual high
but if you respond to it with confusion
and um disgust or fear you get your dark
night of the soul
so actually two sides are the same coin
so there's always going to be experience
on top of realization prior to the fifth
stage
of the natural state which at the purest
level is a realization you cannot
experience no self
everything you experience about no self
is the bible it's
it's not exactly no cell because no self
you cannot locate no self at all
it's like an eyeball that can't see
itself like we said earlier
if an eyeball can see itself you cannot
define it at all you cannot even
experience it
you could say it's not in existence but
that's still
putting a label on it it's basically
when you disidentify from
every single particle in your entire
infinite field of experience
right but then once if you still
identify to even that then there's still
i know this is talk about this this is
this is really important
because this is why these levels
play into what we're
discussing because
it's really important to sort of be
sincere or honest
with which level you're at with each
stage
and sort of the more that you dissolve
your separate self-conditioned identity
the more you stop giving a [ __ ] about
what other people think of you
and because you realize your life itself
and so in a sense to be super honest
with oneself about this process like for
example for me
i feel pretty firmly that infinity's
pretty experiential and getting to the
point of realized
and emptiness is also getting to
a point of like being better and better
experiential
and so for me i'm sort of like
here plus also understanding what
is meant by transcending the entire
paradigm completely because you dissolve
into life itself
and you become an ordinary absolute
normie like the title of our podcast
and i feel like that's why you know
you know enlightenment being a
realization
that's what frank's saying that you know
you're really realizing
the fact that you've went through this
process
of decontracting the energetic
conditioning and separate
self-associations and now
once you've gotten through that process
you realize
that this whole staged system is
completely to be transcended and to not
even be seen as a spiritual [ __ ]
as a spiritual teacher you gotta
dissolve even the halo
on your head see people talk about like
kundalini energies and shotguns right
i mean i went to that phase where i was
like i was a kundalini con i was like
damn all my shotguns opened up now
i'm a badass i have magic now super
powered but then little did i know that
was only the
process of the solution the reason why
you have kanoli energy is because you're
releasing all the
junk of your soul out from your body
to the anus of the third eye that's
it and then i was responding to this
person yesterday in the forum they're
like oh the highest
state of awareness and consciousness is
when you have a lot of energies
and i would say that's not quite true
because the highest state of awareness
is when the body mind actually has no
energy
because if all your chakras open up
you're not going to be able to feel them
once you embody something so thoroughly
that you can't even see them that's when
you really
are it so
in a sense the body mind doesn't feel
energy anymore
but you feel a sort of universal
drive or will to to move around why
the reason why i'm even moving my head
at all it doesn't feel like it's
even when i go to the gym it doesn't
feel like it's coming from an energy
that's within the body
it just feels like the universe is
moving itself
um i would say a lot of uh spiritual
teachers some mystics and sages
the reason why they attract a lot of
followers is because they have a lot of
spiritual energy
spiritual calm but they haven't
dissolved the last speck of the
christians
look this the spiritual count itself
that's why you look at like ramana he's
if i go to rama
okay if you're still on the spiritual
path if you go to romana you might have
experienced like
outer space upon his presence but i'm
willing to bet
if you understand what i'm talking about
here and if you empty out yourself
completely if you go to ramana you're
going to see an old man a diaper that's
no different from trees and whatever
he opens up within you it's not that
he's translating anything to you
because he isn't he's emptied out he has
no energy inside him
whatever you feel during his presence is
that thing that
the willingness of your own body mind
that's allowing this
to take place within you so the truest
form of transmission
is actually the guru being a complete
hollow
holographic straw man just sitting there
and then
upon seeing him he activates something
within yourself
that's the true transmission the
transmitting of
yourself to yourself yep
and you can think about it like a seven
chakra
system and having a potential blockages
happening especially going from like the
solar plexus to the heart
this seems to be the most common one for
people today um
not even getting to necessarily the
state of love absolute love
but then even past that to the throat
and the ajna and the crown
is that what's happening is that
somebody else that has completely
unblocked those chakras
is the guru right is the one that
is holding this truth or channeling this
truth
and then the one that has the blocked
chakras is coming and just being there
with the empty
that has the completely unblocked
chakras
is enabling the unblocking of towards
freedom
basically it's like you illusory created
your own
cage and then the
being in presence of that which is empty
that has no cage is enabling you to be
like
unblock unblock and then get out of cage
out of cage freedom freedom that's a
really good point because the only way
another
another guru can dissolve your condition
is
because he already dissolved if he
hasn't dissolved it he wouldn't be able
to
uh he wouldn't be able to make you
dissolve it in a sense
like you wouldn't okay so let's say this
guru is still he he's
he still has energy in the third eye
like he's oozing out kind of lean juice
and everybody loves it he's vibrant
and if you sit in front of that guru
you can't dissolve the chakra on the
third eye because he hasn't dissolved
his
you know what i mean yeah yeah that's
yeah
you know for example with with me
for example there will be people that
come and talk to
me about doing these unblockings that
we're talking about
but this unit is
of life is limited in its capacity
based on its own unblockings
that have happened so the for
this unit of life can only help unblock
other units of life
that seek to be unblocked based on how
much
this unit of life has unblocked itself
so if you're still at a place where
you're barely in the
on a heart chakra of love which i'm
still
even feeling that i'm learning how to
navigate that
more and more swiftly and frictionlessly
that it's it's gonna be
like it like frank's basically saying it
just boils down to seeing
everything as one homogeneous existence
seeing everything as life [ __ ] itself
without a center you're not
you're not a centered separate
contracted identity anymore but you're
identified with all of life itself
[ __ ] itself
and that you're all of your little
conditionings and by the way it's not
tomorrow
it's that these conditionings will come
up in a month they'll come up in three
months and six months in a year
these little egoic separation conditions
will arise
and you'll be like oh what was taking me
out of
enlightenment basically what was taking
me into a divisive
into a state of division and then you
have to analyze that
truthfully sincerely honestly and then
move yourself
back into a state of oh this is all one
life [ __ ] itself
and that's mentality will sort of help
you purify
there's a quote by nisargata he said um
wisdom is knowing i am nothing a love is
knowing that i am everything and in
between the two poles my life moves and
that sums this up perfectly
the wisdom he's talking about is the
emptiness is the end of the vipassana
path
where you dissolve every single speck of
solidity within your body mind and now
you realize emptiness
but then this emptiness has to be merged
with form
but ultimately empty doesn't form the
same thing but some people
realize emptiness more than form and
vice versa
it's very interesting some people
realize the form aspect of it the
infinity the live
aspect but more than emptiness but the
perfect unification of emptiness and
form
is buddhahood so wisdom
once you reach the end of the wisdom
axis when to realize emptiness
that's our hostage the nirvana
the death the numbing and the buddha
face or the christ consciousness phase
is the infinity face
infinite love universal mind yeah
that's the form aspect of it
and it's the merging of the two that
gives rise to buddhahood when i say
i'm not restricted to the tradition of
buddhism
i'm just talking about your true nature
yeah i'm talking about your true nature
because in a sense emptiness is what
enables you to it's what enables you to
not
have this
perpetuation of mind and
thought that you're attached to it's
what enables you to
just be completely clean of all of those
attachments
and all of those sensations and
perceptions it's like the
windshield wiper you're constantly and
we'll talk about this in a bit just
no sensations touch and so if you can
hold that emptiness
while also holding absolute infinitude
and serving the creation awakening being
a shepherd for it
simultaneously that's
such a profound law yeah that's why i
said the natural state is kind of like a
secession the ninth genre where you just
become completely unconscious you
totally blink out of existence you know
the universe just disappear you pretty
much
you you kill yourself you die before you
die there's not even happiness
there's no awareness at all it's almost
like going back to a dream of sleep
uh but you want to train yourself to get
there instead of just
you know falling asleep the ninth genre
the state of succession or fruition
combined with something like the sixth
genre of infinite consciousness
is the best way i could describe the
natural state you're both alive
and dead you're totally unconscious yet
totally conscious
because it's only when you completely
become unconscious as a separate entity
that you could manifest all of
consciousness
and that's the wisdom of nothingness
plus the infinity of love the
combination of the two
um yeah we can define that more
right now and we have the section on
natty state defined we'll get to
just briefly while you were saying all
of that
i'm just it's just this last little bit
of this this unit of life
that was so attached to its identity
into its separation into all this that
it had built up for
itself to try and extract happiness and
peace and validation and all of that
now dissolving into life itself and
popping it just that whole process it's
just
it's just so it's it's beautiful it's
it's just energetic emotional it's love
that's what it is that that that's the
thing um i have to love when we talk
about absolute love
absolute love and truth and death and
god and reality all the same thing
see absolute love is not something that
the separate character feels from the
heart
even when you have your heart chakras
open up that's still coming from a
separated state
all you want to love everybody you want
to be this compassionate being
right but the absolute love actually has
no emotion going back to what i was
saying about how a full realization
your body might there's no emotions and
no energy in there anymore
it's only the universal energy so the
absolute love
the whole process of spirituality is
about loving yourself so much especially
your shadows especially your
imperfections
especially all your conditioning so you
[ __ ] up this you accept your ego and
your separate state
so completely that you dissolve it
because the only way you can transcend
and dissolve something is to penetrate
it and accept it
and when you accept all of it your
separate self dissolves
out of compassion for yourself out of
love
of self into the love the capital l
of the cell with the capital s and that
process
exactly what we're talking about you're
dying but then you also love it
where death and love becomes two sides
of the same point
you die and dissolve into love and that
is the only way to manifest
all of reality is by dying into
the present moment that's dying into the
orderly of the now and that's love
love without any feels also causes the
the cold love
it's a love without any emotions without
any conditions
because any kind of emotion any kind of
passion is still going to lead to
suffering it's still an attachment it's
still condition
even when you go to the stage of
universal consciousness
of the patasafa when he's like oh i have
to wake everybody up i have to be
discompassionately that's still very
subtle it depends on condition
and when she murders to put the stuff
out with her arhai is still living in
this nirvana they're still in the
dental realm they're so obsessed with
like death and
oh how i'm so much more enlightened than
you all i was in the mountains
right that's the picture in the
tan ox hurting picture in zen buddhism
where the
the seeker has caught the ox he's
wrote it and he's tamed it he's even
playing the fruit
on the ox but he still hasn't like of
enlightenment itself
he still hasn't let go of his own
realization that's why there's a next
picture
going back to the source where there's
just a circle because once you let go of
even the self the remainder of itself
that's identified within
one [ __ ] even the bull the ox also
disappeared
but a lot of people don't want to go
there they still want to be speaking
yeah but then you get something much
more free
after they actually dissolve both the ox
and the self
you go to the source the conical source
that's the emptiness phase
and there's another picture after that
which is just a mountain
that's what i call uni locality
where you look at the mountain it's not
you perceiving the mountain
because there's no perceiver inside the
mountain just perceives itself
it's just the mountain yeah and then you
could be the mountain if you want you
could be the birds the trees the sky
yeah or the meat suit and you're not
identified with any one of them
so that's the difference between uh
non-duality which is one
in the middle stage where you know
everything's one and then
now locality which is emptiness this
identify from even non-duality into
non-locality
and then you have uni locality now
you're a nobody
is somebody and everybody now you're
everything nothing in something
see this somethingness it's oftentimes
missed
yeah because people are like oh oh yeah
i'm nothing or i'm everything but they
haven't real
something yes the first form of unity is
not just oneness or non-duality
yeah it's not just everything is a dream
bro everything is yeah
it's all imagine you're you're nobody
there's no self nor in others
there's nobody here that's to to not
truly radically love and accept
the somebody is to not be
in awe at the firework of the infinite
that you are yeah the the
the firework of the infinite has to
include the particulars or else it's not
infinite
so the deepest form of unity includes
not just the infinite in the oneness
but also the particulars because i see a
lot of people on the non duality track
getting stuck in this idea of how
everything is a dream
and there's nothing to do there's nobody
here
and it's all imagined because true
solipism solipism is really not
different from
egotism it's just a egotism in the god
right your sense of self has been
projected into god
that's why a lot of people have such
huge spiritual egos
because the big self self is god and no
self
they're actually very different
yeah yeah so the somebodiness
the somethingness yet they're two sides
of the same coin yeah they're all the
same actually yeah but
very easy to be attacked but yeah it's
very easy to
also just remain at the intellectual
level
which is really important and just know
that the process of life
reality reveals
and awakens itself to its own nature
over time and so that's the whole point
of the dreamed
process that's that's happening so
that was great we'll get down here you
know in a bit let's go
to we were talking about we didn't go
through the last picture the absolute
normie
the last picture of the zen 10 oxford
picture it's just a guy
the fat guy yeah here why is there
another picture after the mountain
because even like everything we just
talked about you think
you let go of it you got like all that
too and then you just become you just
you just you know whatever bro there's
nothing to be said
yeah yeah yep
and that's also a bit of what emptiness
is empty gives you
as well which is also just empty so
meaning
bro like that's the drinking wine in the
market like
have a [ __ ] good time have have a
have
life have a good time and completely
accept
life exactly as it is that's what gives
you freedom
is when you radically accept life
exactly as it is
you i remember the the moment i realized
truly realized emptiness is also empty
because for a while i was
seeing uh reality to the length of
perception of emptiness i was like
everything yeah everything i can see
everything how everything is one
from separation distance you know the
sky is in the same space as my face
it's all holographic but even that's
just a lens of perception
because sometimes the table is just
stable yeah
sometimes the table is just the table
emptiness is empty
but form is also just for yes
form is emptiness but sometimes
emptiness is emptiness other times
form is also just worn
and so this is sort of what if you guys
have heard
frank talk about the contemplative
fitness ai
um or bentino in his global
enlightenment retreat uses the analogy
of raindrops on windshield as you're in
the car
is that you kind of become sensation
proof
so rather than having the sensation
trigger a conditioning of separate self
rather it's that windshield wiper or
this
contemplative fitness ai that's
constantly running where their gap
between a sensation coming
and you recognizing how
empty the sensation is is
immediate it's immediate you recognize
that it's
all coming empty right away so there's
no
when you get to the really high levels
that there's no
even possibility even anymore
for it to come and create a
elevation of a conditioned contracted
identity you you ultimately that's this
what we're talking about getting to
sensation proofing
yourself would you like to also unpack
this a bit for us frank
yeah so i'm just going to read a post
that i wrote because after i write
something down
i don't really think about anymore so if
i
yes if i summarize it i'll be all over
the place is it on your instagram can i
pull it up
i see my i posted on my story but um i
didn't make a post out of this i don't
think you can see it right now but
i think it's one of uh my highlights but
i'll just read it
yes i think the most direct and clearest
way to put all those different stages of
development in labels
that we've been talking about under
context
is the direct realization the nature of
sensations
now think of sensations as the atoms of
your subjective experience
both inside and outside what a meditator
or a contemplator does is consuming into
deconstruct and dissecting
and dissolving and shred your reality
into sensations at the microscopic level
all sensations are aware of themselves
exactly where they are
all sensations are devoid of full cell
with a small s
and solve for the capital s and
spontaneously and codependently arising
all sensations are in equal
footing so no sensation cause
or own another cluster of sensations
different vibratory velocity of
sensations gives rise
to the difference between conical air
liquid
and solid forms and all sensations
self-liberate so sensations could be
anything from body sensations to
emotions
to sight sounds uh emotions
thoughts basically your entire field of
experience
is made up of sensations so all
sensations are non-dual
as in sensations in and themselves can't
tell the difference
between god poop awareness consciousness
emptiness eternity
love intentions matter mind being sober
or being psychedelic or being
drunk time space etc etc
and since there is only clinical one
substance there is no difference
between the foreground and the
background this is where we talk about
deconstructing all the different stages
and deconstructing even the background
between the context and the contents
right because all sensations are
homogenous therefore phenomenons
do not arise and pass into some source
that is more clinical real and permanent
[Music]
now the labeling of these sensations and
the labeling
of these phenomenons into concepts
is you guessed it just more sensations
you start to see that even
concepts are sensations even labels are
sensations
no different from the things that
they're labeling
so you don't get attached to even
concepts so what's the difference
between the awakened
state in the egoic state now this is
very important
in the former the knots of perception is
forever untied
in the awakened state because the nature
of sensation
is penetrated permanently and
experientially
now all sensations in your entire field
of experience
lights up and are aware of themselves
without a delay
between the subject and an object
between the perceiver and the perceived
observer and then observe the witness
and the witnessing
and this is your moment-to-moment
experience of the clinical godhead of
infinity of eternal awareness
because when sensations are experienced
without a doer control a seer hear a
thinker
all 360 degrees panoramic are known
and comprehended as itself without the
delay
between this or that thus reality
feels omniscient in the egoic state
certain cluster of sensations arise in
the center of experience
usually inside the head being behind the
eyes and in place
in some place inside the body thus
hijacking other clusters or sensations
to clinical take credit for other
clusters of sensations in the field of
experience
and this is all due to conditioning
that's why we talk about observer
being trapped in an observer because
it's taking credit for uh
reality when this happens there's a
contraction of
energy when awareness or the ego is
trying to you know hijack
other fields or sensations to be my
there's a contraction of energy and
that's identification
that's the feeling of meanness that's
where the source of separation comes
from
that's it so when you zoom
experiences down to the atomic level
with max
effort contraction like vipassana where
you can no longer divide it
this singularity ultimately loops back
to the other side
like a strange loop it becomes
infinitely expensive
that's the difference between you know
the contraction method of the passionate
versus the do nothing meditation
we simply just relax and let infinite
consciousness
return to its most natural state so all
those practices
merge as one expansion and contraction
this is why the practice starts out as
dissecting atoms but at the end you end
up repationalizing the whole universe
the very small is identical to the very
large
like the merging of quantum mechanics
and cosmology
love and death at the subjected level
the parts is the whole and vice versa
the atom is the universe now you can get
to the same point either by contraction
or expansion
now we talked about that uh and also you
can you know
do some psychedelic trips have glimpses
of this or
do the contraction expansion method you
know while
uh you are under the influence of
psychedelics uh but
you know i mean in my own path uh all my
insights and
realizations came naturally i mean i've
experimented with psychedelics in my
my twenties and had a few dmt trips
but the reason why i advocate be doing
it naturally is because
i'm just biased because i i i i i give
my naughty man all the credit
anyway so i think that's pretty much it
that was so good
um wait there's another one last part
yeah so when you take to the end point
contraction and expansion
uh just lose meaning and this is when
actual infinity and absolute nothingness
uh emerged simultaneously and this goes
back to what i was saying about how
uh the natural state is like a permanent
succession the unconsciousness of
uh nibana or the 9th genre but also
infinite consciousness of the sikh genre
now if if you don't see
clearly the nature of sensations at all
levels as being empty
and full at the same time and not soft
uh one particular level is always going
to seem more or less real or solidified
than another level that's why
you started to identify with awareness
or consciousness or this or that gossip
because the sensations has been seen
through so one level is always going to
be more
solidified right so that's when again
contraction occurs
identification takes place that's
cleaning and suffering
no so if you understand sensation at the
experiential level
yeah that's it but there are some
pitfalls to this as well
so the contemplative fitness ai enables
cessation at the experiential level yeah
and understanding sensation at the
experiential level
and understanding cessation of
experiential level enables the
master resides in dao the natty state
perpetual
yes but but here's a but i was posting
this on a forum
and then there were some responses
saying this is
by deconstructing experiences only down
to the microscopic
level of sensations can be a little bit
uh
reductive it's almost like a scientist
who only cares about atoms which i don't
disagree with because i've seen a lot of
people that are really into the
viewportion of past they're all about
sensations they see every experience
they just reduce it down to a
microscopic level of sensations
and they're they're more in the
emptiness side of the equation than the
love the infinity and the fullness side
but my counter argument is for those
people they haven't taken sensations all
the way that's why there's a problem if
you take sensations
all the way like i said it loops back to
infinity
maybe you're taking sensations down to
the 99 percent level
but 99 in 100 is quantum
once you deposited sensation down to the
microscopic level
and 100 you dissolve everything boom
it's absolute infinity
which is same as acid nothingness
yeah so that's why you can get to the
same end point by
either doing vipassana in the theravada
path or by doing
uh sort of the zoho chain kind of
practices like do nothing the stop
the saba version of the ocean because no
chain is full this form is the natural
state
but there's some versions of it where
you can do the awareness awareness
practice abiding in consciousness kind
of practice like
the later formless genres kind of
practice if you do that long enough
you also lose back to the to the
microscopic level
yeah but there are i see a lot of people
that sort of
lean towards one side of the of the
duality of the
equation which is really interesting
some people are more energetic they
talk about love a lot you know and then
they they
the way their vibe is is like you know
more more
in touch with the christ consciousness
and bodhisattva path
and some people are more into the
emptiness path if you take
this all the way
you merge the two you do you merge the
two if you take this
all the way this is this is what
this is it take this all the way this
contemplative fitness
ai take it all the way to see sensations
at this most subatomic level
if you do that you will recognize
what we're talking about which is being
sensation proof
and enabling you to reside in
life itself to dissolve into
life [ __ ] itself endlessly yes
one more point so what exactly is a
natural statement
the natural the natural state is just
the fact that
once you see through how all sensations
are in equal footing
once you're not attached one club once
one cluster of sensation isn't hijacking
other cluster of sensations all
sensations appear
exactly where they are as it is okay i
have a question
would this would this be like
today i'll go through this example and
then we'll go to the
next equanimity okay would this be
this i feel like this is gonna funnel
perfectly into this example
um today the the trash
service came and the
other tenants in the building had been
emptying some food and drink and what
not into the bin
so it had created a very big stench over
the week
so i'm bringing the trash bin back after
it's already been emptied by the garbage
truck i'm bringing it back to the house
and i'm realizing that i'm gonna be
washing
the bin out and as i'm washing the bin
out
i realize that washing the dirty
garbage bin that smells rancid is the
exact
same made of the same empty in full
infinitude as having sex or drinking tea
or watching hummingbirds is that okay
yeah
it's just it's just how everything is
just made up of
how scientists will tell you
everything's made up of atoms you know
your god experience is made up of atoms
so is your
uh your poop right and sensation is just
observing and realizing this at the
experiential and the subjective
level so you don't cling on to any
particular state
the ego say if the ego state is just
thinking that all one cluster of
sensation
is more real more solidified because you
haven't uh
seen through it that's contraction if
the state of
awareness becomes this new class of
sensations that
um get solidified then that's also just
another degree
it's another degree that's transcended
from the ego state but if
if there's any preference over any
cluster of sensations
in your field of experience then you
cannot enter a state of
perfect equanimity that's it that's it
when there is no identification with
anything at all sensations can just
appear by
spontaneously simultaneously they're all
co-dependent rising
and they just appear as they are
spontaneous dependent origination
without a contracted conditioned
separate self to have preferences
right right and this preference could be
ice cream or infinite consciousness yes
and attachment to those preferences
which then creates the craving aversion
suffering
yeah yeah that's pretty much what the
natural state is
okay beautiful so let's have you
continue defining this for us
like with here when in the doc so we
kind of talked about this
permanent cessation while conscious
okay well we'll go to the unaltered
state of consciousness so another way to
look at this
is that everything before the natural
state
which is what's already been the case um
is
an altered state of consciousness
the egoic state is an outer state of
consciousness it's insanity
psychotic you think your thoughts are
real you think you're a separate person
that's an algae state
let's take a moment to seriously make
sure that
this is being understood because this is
basically
reversing the entire paradigm of the
world on its head
so it's basically saying that the ego or
separation
and all the conditioning and attachments
of the that contracted energy
entity that is the altered state
that is the altered state of
consciousness is believing that i am
a separate finite physical entity in a
world full of other separate finite
physical entities
that's the altered state and then that's
a really big paradigm shift
okay well i mean moving from that to
uh the outer state of mystical
experiences let's say you're you've been
eating all your life now you took
psychedelics now you think holy [ __ ]
this is so much more real
but that's also an altered state and we
go to meditation we should experience
genres and come to linear awakenings
uh even you know merging with god divine
union cosmic bliss all the stuff you
read about spirituality
from the perspective of the ego saying
that is much more
true and much more spacious and much
more relaxed state
and unaltered yes but but now that's
still an outer state of consciousness
but yes it's more unaltered yeah it's a
little bit
more on outside but it's still altered
yeah yeah well you think this is more
although but
they're both altered yes
they're both altruistic but it's giving
you a taste of the unaltered which is
then what gives you the north star
in the road map yeah right so after you
uh
just identify for all the outstanding
consciousness and slip into the natural
state
that's the unaltered state of
consciousness that's total sanity
because clinging on to universal mind or
the individual mind is the same thing
from the unaltered state of perfect
equanimity where all sensations are in
equal footing
you look at your past uh levels of
identification to realize that
attachment to the solidity of the ego
versus the attachment to the solidity of
mystical experiences are actually the
same thing they both
uh create uh cleanings and suffering
that's why the buddha
said that not only do you have to let go
of the material realm
the form realm you have to let go of the
formless realms yes
but i will go ahead i i just i just
wanted to briefly say that
just to put a little flag in it just
that it is still
really important as people are stuck in
physicalism
to point people towards the formless to
towards conscience of course
yes yes yes that's why the stages are
there yes yes
you just there's some people that just
jump from like stage one to five
they [ __ ] go insane man
how do but here's the thing is the point
that's very important
see the people who hasn't experienced
the non-experience of our true nature
when they only have the egoic state in
the mystical experiences to compare
their experiences with
they're always going to be confused
they're always going to think that
um the uh the outer state of mystical
experiences the god consciousness on
psychedelics or meditation or
spontaneous glimpses
temporarily transcending itself they're
always going to think that's
enlightenment
yeah yeah they're always going to
confuse that with alignment because they
have
they've only got the two outer states to
compare it from of course the mystical
experiences all the unity consciousness
yes
yes it's going to be more enlightened
than the ego yes
there's more to this identify yeah so
that that's why
attaches to the mystical experiences and
says this is it yeah yeah
and before you have a realization which
is the the the locking of
uh the true nature it seems
it's really really difficult to see this
because i've been trying to tell people
the difference between mystical
experiences which is the temporarily
transcendence of the self
which itself always comes back because
it's not a realization yet
versus the permanent drop in the way of
the self with your relationship
geez there's a huge difference there
yeah it hasn't if you haven't had a
realization
and realization can only occur
naturally you there's no realization on
a psychedelic trip when you're hired
i mean maybe there is but like it's so
filtered you can't
extract it right so
when i keep trying to tell people that
dude there is a difference
between a realization and an experience
between dropping away of the center
permanently versus just temporally
transcending yourself
because when you still have a center in
the head when
no matter how crazy this experience is
it's still going to be filtered through
whatever solidity
that's in the head if you're in the
beginning of the path the salinity is
your entire body mind
once you get to the very end of the path
the solidity could be this tiny little
atom
somewhere like in the head somewhere
yeah we're going to get in the way of
infinity
closing in on itself into this cigarette
loop
99 and 100 is quantum
it's a different order together yeah
[Music]
oh man it's just so much of
like a relief
so so that what is what is wisdom what
is inside and wisdom
if i if i may if i may read the
i'll pull it up for people
and for people that are getting kind of
confused and scared i'll just remind you
one thing
wisdom is not something you accumulate
with the mind
or something you read in spiritual books
wisdom is taking away all the falsehood
until you're left with what is now we
talk about a lot of crazy ships like you
know
oh your awareness is going from 720 to
1080 to 4k to 360
8k you're like what the [ __ ] how do i
get that well
let me ask you is reality
panoramic at 360. if so then that's why
you are it's always been the case
it's always been the case does the
universe have a center point
if not that you don't have a center
because you're the universe it's very
simple
and this is the sentence
relief of being literally
nobody
well
relief of being literally nobody that is
when
you're dropping into this emptiness
you're dropping into this no
self you're dropping into slowly into
this natty state you're just kind of
dropping in
easterly and it's just this relief
of not needing to be anyone a relief of
knowing that you're nothing along with
everything
and that you can just peacefully
relax all of the contracted conditioning
that you built up over the years of
wanting to
be seen as an individual wanting to be
seen as a somebody
although we are still that spark of the
infinite like we mentioned
but all of that contracted energy that
built up around
all the conditioning from your childhood
and all of the things of
wanting to impress other people
and to have all of this money and
success and fame and
oh if i just keep or being a spiritual
[ __ ]
just exactly especially that one has
been so important for me recently
to be practicing that one more and more
of just
letting go of needing to be seen as a
spiritual content
seriously so the relief of being
literally nobody the ultimate attainment
is not entertainment
is the last layer between the nirvana is
the last layer of the dream the
brahman once you get so deep you become
brahmana
that's the last layer of the dream you
go so deep you're like humming [ __ ] man
this is a problem and everything's ramen
but even that
could be this identified from ultimate
attainment
is non-attainment
but this is when you have the
reflexivity you can switch lenses again
on monday i'm going to use the emptiness
lights i'm going to go i'm going to have
a tinder day and this theater day is the
buddhist oh i'm going to put on an empty
list list
bro
you're like everything's unified mine
okay we just
we just mentioned this one the relief of
being literally nobody which is great
the dying into the ordinary oh we
haven't mentioned that one
yeah that one's so important
really i i can't really relate to that
one from a direct experience
where you're literally it's like it's
kind of like being a permanent athlete
trip
except it's deeper than that because in
the natural state there's neither
an experience nor a mind right so it's
even deeper than my
experience but it's very similar to
being on asset all the time where
you look at anything at all you just see
the entire universe in there
you don't see infinite like zooms you
just you just it's just timeless it's
just
i don't know you can just like you know
how you're a little kid and just in a in
a sandbox
you just like playing with sand playing
with leaves
just you know looking at [ __ ] and
then there's just no time you don't have
to go anywhere and
that's that's your moment-to-moment
experience in a natural state
yeah and it it i remember
um when i was shifting into the state
when i was still kind of dissolving
when i read that i it i was like holy
[ __ ] this is exactly what it feels like
because it literally feels like you're
you're
every moment is like disjointed right
and each moment you're being reborn and
being reincarnated
and each moment when you look at like i
was swiping my um
i was wiping my ass and then i was like
looking at my poop and i could i could
feel like
just my sense of self just come even the
last back of it just completely dying
into the
into the toilet paper and there's
nothing but the toilet paper you know
what i mean
and but then as long as i move the
toilet that's another a new dimension in
the last one and a little bit where you
literally every moment it feels like
you're really dying into this disjointed
frame
and then after a while it just becomes
uh more stabilized and
once you're all dead you don't feel like
you're dying anymore yeah
[Music]
between life and death gosh and don't
fear this process of
dying know that it's a natural part of
the
spiritual awakening and that
it's only going to make you an even
better steward and shepherd of
the reality awakening to its nature
it'll only make you
more pure
in the process yeah yeah well spiritual
speaking of the
process again there are two major shifts
on the spiritual path one is the move
from ego to being
then move from ego to awareness or
consciousness or god
all that's being stuff the second move
which is
that that's that's painful that's dying
for a lot of people that's
you know that's literally death right
that's very difficult dark nights dark
nights after darkness
the second stage sorry the second phase
the second shift
from being from existence from infinity
to non-being
to nothingness that hurts even more
because you're
letting go of even god yeah that hurts
even more because you're letting go of
this
infinite feel that you thought to be you
you have to decide
from that and that hurts even more
that's why most people don't make it
that far
i always say that um waking up or
dissolving the ego
is uh awakening dissolving even god
is the natural state yeah
now i'm not making a claim about the
ontological existence of god or not oh
that's
completely yeah yeah yeah i mean you
could
you could if you were just using the
word god to reference the highest or the
absolute
you could just use it to reference the
coin that we've been talking about yeah
which is that one side is emptiness the
other side's infinity
yeah that that's why this thing because
in a natural state you can call yourself
a monkey or a god or a human be your
table whatever it doesn't matter
like you go start the difference is
during the during the god phase
i can feel my ego popping up when i look
at the word god
or when i communicate with another
spiritual khan and we're talking about
god realization
i could feel my ego popping up this is
because we associated the word
god with the capital s self this is why
versus if you also
were to associate god with emptiness
or with no self or with tao or the natty
state
then you could say that this is god
in the shape of the coin of emptiness
and infinity
with the you could say consciousness or
awareness as this primary
attribute of the power to know
yeah so so in the natural state you
could
when i say i am god or i am awareness or
a monkey or i'm frankie
it makes absolutely no difference
there's no trigger
there's no preference there's no
contraction of any of these there it is
that's that's the only difference really
but it's all the same the difference
the contraction identification yes
that's it yes beautiful yeah so we're
not ruining any stages
okay the disappearing into the dark
light of the absolute you said this was
a nisargadatta
maharaja phrase yeah uh shantae also
used the dark light to
describe no self um because like we said
before it's almost it's the combination
of
infinity versus nothingness yeah so it's
dark and light
beautiful disappearing and dying into
the extraordinary while manifesting this
infinite consciousness
and field of experience perfect then
let's do life [ __ ] itself and closing
the infinity loop
uh well closing the infinity loop is the
point of making about how if there's
still
a solidity in the body mine or anywhere
in the field of experience
um infinity cannot uh fully
comprehend itself thoroughly yes yes you
know how was uh
the logo or the animation of uh of the
figure eight or
the snake cosmic state fighting for oral
boros yes
yes yeah it's going infinity like this
right if there's a speck in there
it it won't close it won't close yeah so
even that little bit
of even if it's at the level of
even if you've popped beyond the egoic
separation conditioning to
even awareness or
you know consciousness of consciousness
it says even if even if you're there
that even if you've started to taste a
little bit of infinity and emptiness and
when i if you've tasted it
you'll still have these bits of the
separate self
that are there and this is what you're
referencing perpetually which is the
difference between
getting to the point of sort of like 99
percent
dissolving that all the way down to that
yeah
100 percent yeah that's the difference
between you as a separate entity having
an experience
of awareness consciousness or the divine
versus just reality being itself
that's how you feel about it okay it's
not a separate entity
having the realization of the divine
but it's life recognizing
the divine yeah just life being itself
life being itself
yeah saying anything about you know this
process is saying too much even saying
infinity penetrating itself
eternity gazing back itself it's saying
a little bit too much
okay yeah cool that that we just covered
that as well
and that's the difference between like
you know how people get into the later
stages of genres they they get they do
get into infinite consciousness but the
teacher will tell them
hey you're still stuck in the golden
chain of the formless wrong because
they're experiencing infinite
consciousness
as a meditator first dissolution of the
meditator
whether it's only yeah exactly
so rather than having the experience of
the divine
as a separate entity it's life itself
just yeah that's it that's it that's it
again is the difference between
transcendence of the self
which is the quick glimpse and this
glimpse lost sometimes for
months or five seconds versus the
permanent drop in the way of the self
yeah beautiful and life [ __ ] itself
also is deeply
at play with dependent origination as
well
that it collapses the witness
the witnessing and the witnessed into
one
and that's what this uni locality
yeah so dependent origination is very
interesting because
it's basically the notion that
everything is interconnected
everything's interpenetrated and
everything is
you know codependent rising right so
without a u there there won't be me here
and we're all connected to infinite webs
of conditioning right
and the reason why dependent origination
is never talked about
is because without realizing emptiness
and no self you cannot perceive
dependent origination in real time and
then
without perceiving dependent origination
in real time
you're always going to be standing on
the ground for example
the move from ego to consciousness is
understanding that
the self the thinker the ego is just
another thought right
before you used to think that the the
frank yang is the thinker
and this thing is talking about thoughts
but then after streaming entry you
realize that this franking character
this avatar
is just another thought no different
from any of the thoughts it's not the
generator of thoughts
it's not the creator of thought it's not
the thinker of thought it's in itself
it's just another thought that's empty
with no one behind it
popping in and out of nothing no
different from any other thought
that's stream entry to move from
instrumentary to
the later stages you have to apply that
process of self-inquiry
into the big self into even the god mind
now if dependent origination is true
then consciousness or the ground of
being whatever ground of being
that you identify yourself with either
the skoda mine or brahman
that's also dependent originating
because consciousness
is the result of the dependent
origination
between the observer perception
uh the object of perception it's
dependent on
all kinds of stuff to be able to you
know generate this experience of
consciousness
totally a lot of people stand on the
ground of consciousness
because they don't understand dependent
origination and then again that's very
easy
very easy to identify or just drop them
directly into the dream analogy
when you when you dream at night
everything
is dependently originating on
everything else although there is
a point of in the sense you're viewing
it as
the in the sense the power to know
in the dream from a specific spot itself
you the tree
is the same thing as the power to know
the other
person is the same thing as the power to
know it's all
in the life [ __ ] itself the dream
[ __ ] itself
dependent origination that there there's
no separation between
anything of that substrate it's all just
one homogeneous dream
there's no inherent existence to any
particular object
either that's consciousness or a
basketball
a basketball is a no thing the only
reason the basketball is the thing is
because it's depending on the color of
the leather
the leather itself the game of
basketball uh
the you know the roundness of the ball
right
and the person playing it all those
different factors have to come together
to give
rise to a basketball without all these
different
you know website conditions there won't
be a basketball you can apply that to
any objects in the universe i see so
so the thousands of years of webs of
conditioning around
the idea of being a human being for
example is like the most important one
that gets blown out
and once the dependent origination of
all the webs that have been structured
for thousands of years of
being a human being gets blown out
that's when
there's this no mind no self
that gets you can just look at whatever
is arising right now anything you can
see right now is depending on rising
yeah everything just like this meets
with the eye the nose the hair
the screen everything is just dependent
rising through each other
and this is when you really please
hopefully people construct the ground
yeah and see that even consciousness see
okay
here's the point the people that think
consciousness
is the ground of being um it's it's very
easy to
deconstruct that have you ever had a
dreamless sleep in your life
if you have then consciousness is not
permanent ta-da
for something to be permanently and
ultimately true
it has to be the case for every single
bling on the planet throughout entire
history of civilization
afterwards and beyond now if you
grandmother had a dream of sleep
last night then consciousness is not the
ground of being
and that's typically why they call it
shunya or emptiness
yeah yeah because nothing has any
hearing existence
right not even consciousness and if you
you know train your mind to have
successions or fruitions
uh when you consciously make
consciousness disappear and then
reappear and see how those
differentiations yes yes
reconstruct and deconstruct moment to
moment you see that consciousness is not
permanent
if it's not permanent it cannot be the
ground up being the only thing that's
permanent the only ground you can say
is impermanence because everything is
permanent the only permanent is
impermanence
yeah yeah yeah so so consciousness or
awareness or the power to know can be
potentially referenced to as the first
attribute
like the way that we can
perceive reality actually we could do
i i feel like dependent origination
should be a conversation that we have
um in exploration because this is a much
like
later stage understanding that i think
is
like it collapses everything into unit
locality yeah
yeah it's just like those notes yeah
have you seen those picture of this like
a circle where every
point is connected to any other point
but it's also
every point is also connected to itself
that's pretty much
what different origination is and
without okay so so in a sense it's also
like what
in mathematics um we look at
things like graph theory and we look at
all these
different um vertices and edges
and so everything is vertices and edges
everything
is those relationships yeah there's no
notes there's only the the there's only
vertices
but then see even depending origination
in the natural state
but but don't you want you
say that you're like mind body spirit
complex in the dream
is itself could be called a node even
though it's creating an illusory
it's creating an illusory box it's still
so so there's all these different layers
where we could say that it's a node okay
okay
yeah even even the fact that let's let's
say okay we're talking about dream using
the dream as a metaphor oh everything in
the gym
is dependent rising but you can even
take the whole level of the dreamscape
and say
dream is dependent arising through
reality
yeah yeah cool and then that's another
note right there right and then you
start to see that oh
neither dream nor reality is the ground
of being
that's how you start to construct
reality into union locality
through the the inside of dependent
origination
um yeah but but but here's the thing
though either natural state of
independent origination doesn't exist
so what so then what yeah so keep unpack
that for us
why not because well after you have very
deep
deep
inside of dependent origination the most
i can say about dependent origination
operating through your real time is that
you feel free because
when you walk it's just the universe
walking when you eat it's just universe
eating in
every part within this hall is
doing its best to make every particular
thought
every little action perfect yes so but
at this stage you don't think about it
in the middle stages you contemplate on
a dependent origination you know
meditation you're like
how does this link to that concept okay
so
other than that and it's just embody
experience of
perfect so so it would be something like
when you when you eat
a little handful of blueberries
that it's life the universe
eating blueberries not uh you you don't
not this identified unit itself you can
say that it's a
you can say that it is um its own mind
body spirit accomplish you can say that
but you've gone past the stage of
separation so you're the universe or
life
eating blueberries but in order for that
to have happened
there had to have been this whole entire
process of
hundreds of years of learning how to
perpetually grow blueberries in specific
climates and having
the modern day farmer go through the
process of of growing it and then
shipping it to you going and earning the
money to be able to purchase it bringing
it back having it first restored and eat
it
taste it poop it out later have that go
through the water sanitation process
but you don't think about that the whole
time
you're just in the infinite possibility
space of now
yeah you don't think about that you can
if you want sometimes those thoughts do
pop in my head well that's amazing but
it's not something you consciously
contemplate anymore
um yeah just if you're looking at
blueberry
you what makes the blue very tasty and
what makes you appear
uh blue is you know all those different
mechanisms in your nervous system
um plus the texture of the blueberry
plus everything that you said
right plus the location of the tree over
there
that's why i'm sitting over here there's
just too many infinite
notes to deconstruct but cool that's the
point that's the point
yeah okay so there's no there's no
center to anything nothing is causing
another thing everything is co-dependent
and rising
spontaneously perfect
yeah perfect codependent arising
spontaneously aka
rikpa
divinity recognizing itself
this is the sort of the last one that we
kind of talked about this versus the
separate self-perceiving divinity
we talked about this okay cool and then
we didn't get to ramanus quote yet
we mentioned a little bit but the quote
goes the world is illusion
brahman alone is real the world
is brahman so this closes the loop on
non-duality
pretty much yeah so with this little
quote
if you truly realize i understand this
quote
there's no illusion there's no world
there's no problem all those different
distinctions avoid
yes there you go that's it that's it so
it's not like at the end the word is
prominent that's still
too much you can use maya to describe
the illusion
and the intoxication of the separate
entity trying to get peace and happiness
from it
you can use the process of calling the
the
world transient and therefore less
real than the empty infinitude
and that you can do that process
it's helpful but in the ultimate the
world is brahman closes the loop to say
that
there is absolutely no distinction
to being between brahmin and the world
yes so the war's illusion is kind of
like jumping from ego to stream entry
and then you start to identify with
you know god and brahma you're like oh
only brahman is real i am brahman i am
god
then you realize the word is brahma you
realize some samsara is nirvana
you let go of even the entire paradigm
of spirituality
yes just and this is why
in the neo advaita direct
pointings that they're just saying that
this is the absolute yes of course yeah
this is
absolutely right right here absolutely
this absolutely the only thing i can say
about the absolute
it's like this is a cup yeah perfect
[Laughter]
perfect complete absolute normie bra
yeah cool and we went through these
earlier let me get
let me make one last really important
point before we go to practices
yes there's a there's a trapping that i
need to point out
is that with the non-duality teacher a
lot of teachers will tell you what we're
telling you right now that there's
nothing to do you're the enlightened
everybody's enlightened there's no such
thing as enlightened being because you
don't have a self
yeah sure that's all true or like
people hear me talk about the natural
state and they're like hey i'm a normie
i'm in a natural state now right
because i've talked to people about a
natural state they're just like okay i'm
in a natural state
it's true ultimately but relatively it's
not true
because the natural state um
the natural state of the natural state
actually experientially
feels very different from the
the natural state from the egoic
perspective because you have to be
sensation
proof if you're not sensation proof
you're not living in the natural state
they all have the same sensations but
there is a huge difference
why would anybody go through a spiritual
path yeah you've become sensation proof
you have the contemplative fitness ai
running
and so as soon as you see the triggering
thing
it's immediate yes emptiness liberated
yeah
yeah perfect
that's that's mission critical i totally
agree because people will be like
this is the absolute done great and then
they'll continue having the fire of
samsara running all the time of some
samskaras and vasanas
they'll have all of these little sort of
ways of attachment and desire and
craving happening
and they'll keep perpetuating suffering
and so eventually even they turn further
inward
so yeah i think the two most important
indicators of
whether or not you're making progress on
the spiritual path is emotional and
perceptual
is there a permanent shift in the
reduction of suffering
yesterday or is there a permanent shift
in perception
when i talk about moving from like 720
to 1080 to
4k to 360 ak something like that yes
that's great i'm almost shifting
perception
if there's a permanent shift in
perception there's gonna be a permanent
reduction of suffering too because your
perception is being white that's right
that's right
it's not about how much intellectual
knowledge you've gained or how much you
can articulate it how much
uh better you get debating with another
spiritual kind about what truth is what
reality is
all that's relevant as [ __ ] is right now
in your moment-to-moment direct
experience how much
has your contemplative fitness ai uh
been upgraded
perfect and so contemplative fitness ai
can be broken down
into two components one emotionally how
much less do you suffer
if at all um and then the second one
is that how you how you perceive do you
see an
8k uh do you see the dependent
origination do you see
life all as just life at play
there's no separation between objects
you like physically viscerally
not just an idea i was like oh depending
on origination i'm imagining that
uh there's no separation there's a
difference there yeah
the full collapse of the witness the
witnessing and the witness
huge perceptual change upon that
relation
that's why what i keep saying that
realization is really a kind of a
perceptual gift to what is
because when you say realization people
tend to confuse it with something
intellectual
yeah perceptual
and the emotional eradication of
suffering yeah
yeah which plays into that moment to
moment like you're describing i like
those two
those two are definitely what i've also
experienced and also been able to
sample this meta pattern of what other
people have been
undergoing in their awakenings as those
are the key things
this absolute nirvana or blown out of
suffering
and then the other one is this
perceptual upgrade to
this is empty fullness yes empty
fullness exactly the
the new operating system new os yeah
it's always
like a new one it's like a new operating
system yeah recognizing
that's why that sufi metaphysic quote
only the ignorant secrets already there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
so
yet it remains for you to recognize the
natty state
to recognize these two things that full
blown out suffering
no longer perpetuating misery for
yourself and for the world
and two is the perceptual upgrade
to see everything as empty fullness yeah
and then you can fluidly switch between
these lenses of perception
and sort of help um people as they come
to you
um and also engage with the world across
these lenses
yeah i keep emphasizing that no self is
just another lens
like ultimately there's no if you're
understanding sensations there's no
difference between no self itself right
so some people always after realization
of knowledge of always wear the lens of
no self
and they can't interact with people
sometimes you need to put on the lens of
self even though
even though after realization the lens
of self is
also experienced as no self that's it
yes yes yes you can play the role of
frankie and not identify with him
versus where you know somebody says
shitty about frankie oh he's on
he's not natty bro and then he gets hurt
right yeah
so there is a difference between
switching on the lens of self so you can
interact with other people in a more
healthy way versus um
not seeing that they're uh the self and
knows how they're different right
you know i mean it's hard putting on
this there's a percentage of self
through the realization of no self is
very different from
only being stuck with the length of self
of self
cool and then you
were mentioning this you know the buddha
is the one that has completely gone yet
also
is the one that is turned towards form
in
serving shepherding the awakening
and you mentioned that throughout that
we have these different
parts of the practices that can be done
i'll i'll just be
super these have totally played you know
we've been mentioning this several times
is that
atlas has went under a similar path as
frank in this process
and not only with vipassana and
zogchen and with entheogens and with
self-inquiry
but also really i had no real idea
about this like really what you
what can be done upon specifically when
you get to
this more popped state
of awareness or consciousness itself
that if you sort of just like do nothing
and relax as that more and more
of this infinitude and emptiness this
empty fullness
ends up opening up as you do more of
this just
relax for an hour and just
be and as you sort of relax in that i am
as you sort of just relax in that you'll
sort of have these profound
empty full realizations that will deepen
your
the realization further and further so
that when you go out to the grocery
store
you're having more of that no self and
the capitalist self
you know you're you're you're any
able to sort of more easily
be in that in that natty state and i
really didn't even know that much about
this
do nothing style process
it's like you literally just on the
couch
in the living room just your an easy way
to do it is by just
noticing the actual space itself like
nobody's looking at this space right now
we're we're only looking at the form
we're only looking at the form itself
this
you know this windscreen on the mic or
this atlas and frank unit or the screen
that we're watching this on right now
but nobody's looking at the space itself
between
the witness and the witness
um the witnessing itself or just the
space itself and so just
in a sense holding that space enables
the empty fullness to sort of
blossom from that at least i've noticed
that a bit from the do nothing process
it's been interesting yeah we should
talk about oh yeah the do not think
meditation is
all you really have to do is relax the
any tensions in your body feel
your body mind if you notice any tension
just relax it and awareness will
automatically return to itself
yeah and then there is a subversion of
those chin that's kind of like where you
talk about where you sort of
make the emptiness into form where you
kind of perceive the
the emptiness of form in the form of
emptiness so you actually try to like
draw
emptiness because first you penetrate
form as emptiness
and then you make the form out of
emptiness and until the emergence one
so i went through these as well so you
kind of just like realize the space
between objects
and you make the emptiness into like a
thing
so you can see that their formations are
identical that's that's a really fun
practice
yeah i like how you describe it as
simple as also just relaxing
and then just watching those tensions
just dissolve
and then you just recognize that this is
it like welcome to the absolute just
pure
not attached to any separate
self-identity needing to do
this or that just you'll like it's
literally as simple also as like
when you go to like the fridge notice
you
like you walk to the fridge completely
aware you know
yet utterly ineffably transcended
walking to the fridge
you like you know you're following the
script of opening the door to the fridge
and looking inside
but then all of a sudden you go
and you just pivot your attention away
from the action of what you were doing
and for that moment you're just realized
that full empty fullness again
and then you're back into the physical
action of what you were doing at the
fridge
it's almost like you can take a moment
like you're walking
and then you just stop like literally in
the middle of the sidewalk
just a full 100 stop
and just
wow and feeling into that empty fullness
while you were doing the script of
walking you pause yourself fully full
stop
stop describing stop symbolizing stop
anything
and just
allow relax into that empty fullness
and then you go back onto the walk and
then eventually the walk becomes the
empty fullness as well
and so they don't become two things but
at least the start
it's really good to sort of like pause
yourself repeatedly
like do this style of pausing and
realizing perpetually until it becomes
your moment-to-moment experience yeah
cool all right that's that was a
two-hour absolute normie [ __ ] yeah
well we gotta talk about self-inquiry
really quick let's do it
because we talk about the passion now
with the sensation power we talk about
the do not do meditation to access
um infinite awareness but we have to
talk about self-inquiry because i think
that's
actually the most effective way to get
to the yes yet both of us have made
plenty of content also on the specific
topic
itself but yes let's do it anyway oh
we've talked about it before
well you and i have both made content
about this oh okay
yeah so basically self-inquiry is just
to
objectify everything until there's no
subject so whatever you can perceive
look at
observe experience you can objectify
so if you go through all the stages at
first you objectify the ego and then you
start to objectify
the mind and consciousness and awareness
and everything and you objectify even
this sense of no-self you objectify even
emptiness
because if there's an exterior it's
still an experience there you can stay
objectified
once you objectify everything then
there's no room for the subject and
there's no room for the subject
is very tricky it's not like this
subject is
it's it's not nothingness either because
that's still something
that's it i won't go
too deep here because we talked about
this before you reminded me so
um another just sort of simple way is
just
asking who or what am i and then you can
sort of if you
if you really like bentino has been
really adamant about just getting people
to go
that i am god just go all the way up to
the absolute go all the way there first
and then see yourself the way that god
sees you
see yourself the way that the absolute
see see yourself the way that life
sees itself and stop seeing yourself as
a separate finite contracted entity
trying to extract
for your peace happiness and safety and
whatnot and so
if you do that process of who or what am
i you can sort of
jump up to that level and then like
fight off all of the person separate
conditioning which i've also found to be
really just like fast rapid um stop
taking 40 years
just [ __ ] you know six months a year
like we're gonna power through this much
faster
um moving forward for but then here's
the thing though
even abiding in the absolute god there's
a
another step to disidentify from even
that so i think that point is very
important because i think a lot of
people miss that point
is when you when you when you observe an
observer when you witness the witness
you're going to run to a wall or when
you start
identifying with the god head you're
looking at the wall as the absolute
before you complete dissolve you can
still disappear
into the absolute
disappear into the observer where the
observer the observed and the observing
role into one
so i think that little step right there
like this identification of
even infinity so you can disappear into
infinity instead of being still a very
subtle form of duality emerging
where you still you kind of identify as
a very important
yeah cool cool so let's
wrap um there's a bunch of
comments i love you all frank loves you
all we're super grateful for you thank
you everyone for tuning in
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah fam absolute normie
fam
[ __ ] yeah infinite bra eternal bra
middleweight bra absolute normie brah
thank you guys
thank you thank you
as you guessed it yeah got this down
boom
[Music]
and we have your questions that you've
lined up for the ama
we're gonna get to that also um
so stay tuned that will also be another
separate episode
so thanks for submitting all your
questions there let us know your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode
check out frank's links in the bio below
to his youtube channel and his instagram
he's constantly posting really good
stories for you to check out
um that detail more of this out in depth
also his youtube videos have been very
profoundly awakening to many of us
so go and check those out especially his
most recent distillations have been
great he just just published
two very powerful recent videos and
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet subscribe to frank's channel if you
haven't yet
and share the video with people that you
feel like this would
powerfully resonate with and like the
video as well
and that is all
i'm reading the comment is that life
yeah we've been getting some live
comments all right much love everyone
much love everybody wait so wait the q a
is not we're not going to do we're going
to do it on the other and the second
episode
yeah okay so we're going to report right
now right we're going to end right now
much love bye everyone bye